[Music]
so
we're 16 28
we are now playing very interesting
games let's continue the strategy of
playing super aggressively
with white and very solid chess
with black so let's see
what the pool brings us we're black
against krishna somo
and let's go with the karo khan we have
yesterday thank you timber gifting to
zathar
so d5 and he takes d5 okay so he plays
some sort of a weird
exchange caro generally knight f3 is a
little bit inflexible
let's see what he does probably d4 yeah
okay so this is an exchange karokon
there's nothing particularly um
there's not much going on here black
simply develops the pieces
the one thing to understand is that this
bishop on c8
uh often doesn't have a good home so
it's worthwhile to develop this bishop
either immediately to g4 or to start
with knight c6 and then play bishop g4
so knight c6 so that's a bit of a
limited mentality i think
lucky speed runs so c3 which is fine
and again we can go bishop g4 we can go
knight f6 we can develop in any order
that we want to the one
whoops i almost knocked my mic out the
one um
drawback of going bishop g4 in this
particular position
is that he has this queen b3 move to hit
the b7 pawn
so i'll violate the rule that i just
said let's start by developing the
knight and see what he does
this should be five okay again that's
not a very common way of playing it's
certainly not
bad i mean it's totally fine for white
but we're very comfortable as black here
so
we should develop the bishop on c8
bishop to d7
is very sensible unpinning ourselves
that's totally fine
but uh bishop g4 is also totally fine
we're not afraid of this pin
the pawn is defending the knight he
can't really pile up on this knight
and the only way he would be able to is
knight e5
so let's let's go to g4
queen to d3 that's a pretty good move
um it does unpin the knight
and so in the karo khan in the exchange
caro you often want to give this bishop
away for the night
and then you can develop very peacefully
without having to worry that the bishop
is going to be caught behind the pawn
chain
so that's what we're going to do bishop
takes f3 it seems a little bit odd to go
bishop g4 takes f3 but
that is one of the proper ways of
playing these structures you want to
eliminate the piece that's going to get
caught
under uh or behind the pawns
queen a4 yeah queen a4 i'll talk about
afterward
so where do we want this bishop we can
go bishop b7 we can go bishop d6 either
move is okay
um they both have a strength and a
drawback bishop d6 is more active but it
allows what move
bishop d6 is more active but it allows a
little bit of an unpleasant response in
timber with a five
thank you it allows bishop g5 that could
be a bit of a nasty pin
and bishop e7 is slightly more passive
but
it takes the sting out of bishop g5 so
you could weigh the two um
and compare them what you could also do
is play the move h6 to stop the g5 and
then try to go bishop d6
oh not king d6 bishop d6 so yeah we can
do that h6
i i don't like delaying the development
of the bishop for too long but
given that our position is as solid as
it is this is totally fine
bishop d6 yeah the guy is playing very
very well he's developing
nicely so the position is about equal he
takes we take
taking on c6 was not necessary on his on
his part
and uh we should probably castle
but if we're really if we if we
delve down into the finesse here this
knight on b3
you guys should notice that it's
eventually going to access
the outpost on c5 and it's going to do
that under the condition
that the bishops are traded so
if you look positionally white wants to
go bishop f4 and offer a trade of
bishops and in the event of a trade
this knight on b3 is going to have
access to that outpost
so what move comes to mind to perhaps
prevent
the bishop from coming to f4 it's a
typical karaoke move
and we should start with it because it's
a healthy move on its own
and it prevents bishop f4 so this bishop
doesn't have a good developing square
e arms thank you and dijiang thank you
as well
there is however a drawback and this is
a bit hard to see
the moment you played queen c7 i'm
noticing that the knight
is a little bit loose this pawn on g7 is
kind of overloaded
so if we were to nonchalantly castle we
would allow
the very thematic sacrifice bishop not a
sacrifice tactic bishop takes h6
it's a classic overloading capture so
we should delay castling and
uh play one of several moves how can we
improve our position to prevent bishop
takes h6
it's a pretty um let's see
king e7 is a little bit extreme knight
e4 94 is what i was looking for
put the knight on our own outpost but
some of you have also been proposing
very sensible
a5 with the idea of a4 trying to chase
the knight away
and if the knight goes to c5 when the
bishop is still here then of course we
simply take
i quite like the move a5 i think that's
a very nice positional move
now he can simply play a4 what does
black
gain if he plays a4 and this is a like a
conceptual thing
okay so he does go knight c5 in which
case we
very happily take ruining his pawn
structure
and still we shouldn't castle because of
bishop h6 now is the time to go knight
e4
now is the time to go knight e4
you would push c5 yeah c5 is a is a
sensible move although it opens up the
position and we're not castled yet
that's what i was a little concerned
about now of course
um we can go f5 to support the knight
he might want to sacrifice the exchange
i'm not too concerned about it
so i would say let's just castle first
against another gm i might go f5 to
prevent the exchange so i don't see him
sacrificing though so
we can castle it's fine
okay so we've got a great position we
now want to go f5 we have the b
file uh and if he remains on c1 then we
can tie him down he goes b4
okay now do we want to take on before is
the first question
yes or no why or why not
should we take knight c5
yeah i actually missed that we could but
it's it's not worth it i think castling
was still pretty good baz does thank you
we don't want to take because that
leaves this pawn structure that corrects
this pawn structure
it does open the a file so there's a
case to be made there
but frankly he's not threatening to take
on a5 so we should maintain
that as it is we have the move queen e5
that's interesting
we also have the move for captain b8
also interesting
but let's begin by cementing this knight
with him of f5 let's begin with the most
flexible move and then
see where what he does
yeah i am
okay queen h5
all right so obviously um
he's yeah this guy is very good queen h5
um one sec an h5
what is he sort of what is he doing i
don't really see a threat
actually i do kind of see a thread he
well maybe bishop h6 but
now that's not serious so the first
thing that occurs to me when he plays
quinn h5 is that he's
he's moving his queen away from the c3
pawn
and if we take the punt immediately then
he takes on e6
with very complicated position so
while we can't take the pawn immediately
there is a move which we could have
played previously that i think now
becomes a very strong move to pile up on
this pawn with another piece
that move is of course queen e5 i'm
gonna play it a little bit quicker
because we're down
on the clock thank you jakey boy i
appreciate it
um i have a books command
all right
it also pins the pawn to the rook so if
he goes f3
which he does we can play the very
simple oh there is knights hg3 that's a
cool move
but i was honestly thinking about queen
takes c3
just taking on c3 attacking both of his
rooks
let's see what he does
okay
so he does have oh wow he saw it oh my
god i did not expect him to see this
move
uh frankly because this is a counter
attack
on uh he's sort of defending his rocks
and counter-striking
okay let me think for a second this guy
is a lot better than i thought
so yeah rook f6 is what i'm leaning
towards f6 bishop e3
yeah i kind of underestimated this move
honestly
we can also just take
yeah yeah we should just take let's just
take it
queen g6 is extremely strong we have to
go back
he takes we go here we're gonna get an
end game
and i think that in game is better for
black still
but yeah we take everything he takes we
take we still have very very strong pawn
chain
but it's not gonna be easy to win this
well until that move because he just
blunders another pawn no his position
collapses here
i think i found uh the best the best
sequence there
yeah i mean i saw bishop h6 out of the
corner of my eye but i didn't think it
was as strong as it is
yeah now we're winning because we've got
this pawn chain it's because rogue b3
it's definitely very very underrated
um now if we go rook b7
yeah let's go rook b7 to defend the pawn
and if he goes
a3 we can't take on a3 but what we can
realize is that he's not threatening to
take on b4
that's the key insight he's not
threatening to take on b4 so we can
simply make a move that we would make
otherwise so this pawn on c5 is an
isolated pawn i'm looking at it
i'm saying well how can i attack the
spawn there's
two ways we can go rook a5 or rook b5
both moves look pretty good to me uh
rogue b5 has the advantage of putting
the rook on the defended square
so i would go rook b5
king a f2
that's actually very very strong as well
let's just take here though no it's not
as strong as positive vibrations thank
you
we just take on a3 force the trade
and then take another pawn this is
actually we
we could go d4 but let's just take
yeah no he's very very good this guy
very good
so let's let's go here let's start
pushing our pawns
let's start pushing our pawns
okay let's check him and then push again
push basically just pushing it up
push up yeah d4 this is very simple
rook c2 paving the way for e2
yeah but after the game because i'm i'm
low on time
so i'm sorry not to explain these moves
e2 threatening to promote i mean here
very very simple just d3
pushing baby that's right
yeah he finds i mean he is super
resilient so here one trick that you can
do
well first of all let's push the c4
button there's no rush
there is zero rush um
we can even push it to c3 but we should
bring our king up just to make sure
okay now
well yeah let's just think
damn yeah we're gonna have to basically
win it the long way it's not so simple
to even push the pawns here he's finding
a way to like
hold everything down amazingly
so one plan of of winning this is just
to get the king around to c3
that's what we're doing here he's got to
go back
here here
get the king to c3 and prepare movie two
if we want to be extra fancy
if you want to be extra fancy we can
sacrifice two of our pawns
um and transition into a winning king
and pawn end game does anybody see this
tactic
what am i talking about here you can
sacrifice two of your pawns and force
the trait of rooks that's absolutely not
mandatory but it is possible
nice some of you are seeing it you can
go e1 you promote to a queen forcing the
rook to be on the same file as the king
and now um rookie two check
take it
king c3 king b2 rolling out the red
carpet
so here you could go king b3
you could go in d3 but he wants to get
to c1 so the move is king b2
now the carpet the red carpet has been
rolled out c3
you can simply go c2 and
c1 queen and swing
all right we're good sorry for the
pre-moves at the end
okay
so yeah that was a very uh very
difficult game
i have to say let's check
no but that's not too difficult you just
once you made like 80 000 times it
becomes easy
yeah no that was good good accuracy okay
so let's analyze this and we're gonna
call it because i'm i'm like running out
of gas
all right so basically
the the game started and like knight f3
takes takes d4 is pretty inflexible if
he wants to play an exchange
caro you should start with d4 and then
the most clinical way of playing this is
bishop to d3
this is uh what is considered to be the
most accurate move order because
because you are preventing the bishop
from coming to f5 and
coming to g4 the one of the the
points of the exchange car is to force
this bishop to remain on c8
so for example after knight c6 you don't
play knight f3
that's a positional mistake right you
play c3
again delaying the development of the
knight if knight f6
then you first develop this bishop so
you're developing all of the pieces in
order to
make it as hard as possible for black to
get this bishop out now black can still
go bishop g4
but now it has this move queen b3 and
things start getting a little bit nasty
with his pawn being hanging
and this bishop is just sort of neither
here nor there it's like
you know staring into space so it can be
easily chased away
i hope that makes sense so that's
considered to be the the best way of
playing the exchange kara which is
one of the best weapons against the
kurukhan by playing knight f3 first he's
allowing us
uh easy access to either of these
squares okay so we go knight f6
this should be five and bishop g4 now
sky you asked about queen a4
and the funny thing is queen a4 is quite
a good move actually
because the the thing is
if we go queen c7 white has
uh knight e5 when things legitimately
get quite scary
everything i mean three pieces are
attacking c6 you should probably go
bishop back to d7
now i can bring the bishop out to f4
it's clearly an initiative for white
probably not bad for black but it's
unpleasant
now what i was planning to do here is a
very advanced idea
an idea that appears to be a blunder
bishop takes f3
why does this appear to be a blunder i'm
going to make it a little bit um
one moment i'll be right back wait where
is the game oh there it is bishop takes
f3
now why does this look like a blunder
who can tell me what does white have in
this position
that seems to win at least upon and
maybe even the game well not g takes f3
obviously
bishop takes c6 queen takes c6
and we're busted because of queen d7 we
drop the rook
we have to play this terrible looking
move knight d7 but
it's all an illusion it's all an
illusion
whoops sorry i keep promoting the wrong
line it's all an illusion
and after e6 i claim that black is not
worse here
at least from a practical standpoint
this is a hard concept to understand for
a lot of players because
optically the position may look bad for
black you're down upon white seems more
active
but it's kind of pseudo activity if you
if you look at it more
carefully you'll notice first of all
that white is not developed
the illusion of activity comes
merely from the queen being far advanced
but that's not a good thing you'll chase
it away with rook c8
that's just not a big deal at all
and then yesterday we talked about
static versus dynamic factors static
factors
are things that are unlikely to change
static weaknesses for example
and white has one very major
static defect in his position that
constitutes
most of black's compensation what am i
talking about
it's what is wrong with white's position
here
it's it's the the ruined kingside pawn
structure because
the pawn structure itself is an issue
black has very easy access to the f3
pawn but
more of an issue is the fact that white
essentially can never castle kingside
white's king is a huge problem now you
might say well it's not such a big issue
right why can castle queen say but
that's also very subpar
because white has advanced a bunch of
his queenside pawns
so castling queen side is not going to
solve any of white's problems either
this knight on d7 you can think about it
coming out to c4
black's got the semi-open b file so
black's got the weapons to attack the
queen side already at the ready
so it's just black's got a lot of
activity here
and it and it's all contingent on black
completing his development which he's
going to do
you know for example let's say bishop e3
or something rook c8
you could even sack the a7 pawn i don't
give a damn about that pawn bishop d6
knight d2 castles and white's king is in
trouble
because if castle's this way well you've
got this knight b6 is very strong i
think people get the point
it's hard to evaluate um
these types of positions but it's
important not to fall into this illusion
uh when a queen is active that the
position is bad the queen
alone is rarely uh something that you
can't deal with
and black doesn't have any targets
uh i i don't know if that makes sense
but that's what i plan to do
obviously if white doesn't take on f on
c6 then you could play queen c7 you
could play
queen b6 or c8 or c cm might be
inaccurate but
even queen d7 is fine
um okay when you give up the a pawn
are you not afraid of the two past pawns
no
because oh you mean here
no because i think i'm gonna check mate
white long before these two pass pawns
make their presence felt of course in
the long run if flight consolidates
i'm going to pay the price for this but
i just
intuitively feel that black's attack is
is so strong here that
these pawns are not going to get very
far if that makes sense
if is bishop g5 scary it's a little bit
unpleasant
uh because if you take on g5 you drop
the rook that's the whole idea
you also can't play f6 well never play
f6
and bishop e7 doesn't really help
because of bishop takes c7 but i think
you do have queen b8 first of all
although that's not ideal and perhaps
you can play bishop e7 and simply take
with the king
and then you can castle by hand rookie
king f8 not
great but better than nothing and it
preserves the
general landscape of the position so
yeah bishop g5 is i think white's best
move
okay so in any case that was
an opportunity our opponent had he went
queen d3
so we take this opportunity to get rid
of the knight otherwise knight e5
is super annoying takes takes
well sprintly is the g file is not
dangerous
and uh it's it's important not to
overestimate
the role of these files because you
simply go g6 and the rook is biting on
granite my favorite term
when you've got a situation like this
even if you put your king on g7
this is a tremendously solid pawn in
order to break down this defense
white's going to have to pile up on this
pawn with this one and still that's not
going to be enough
the open files themselves are not always
guaran you know
they don't always guarantee that you're
going to have a strong attack
also no dark squared bishop to occupy
the dark squares weakened by the move g6
which makes this
possible to play the king is very very
safe on
on the g pile here queen d3 takes takes
e6
okay that's good we've got a solid equal
position here
but our opponent has handled the opening
quite well
okay so castles h6
we um yeah again bishop d6 is possible
i didn't want to allow bishop g5 had we
allowed this
i would have played h6 anyway
and after bishop takes f6 we would take
with the queen
and this pawn structure is nothing to
worry about given that it's an end game
but it is an opposite-colored bishop and
game that's more of the reason i didn't
want to go for this
i was a little bit worried about the
triage tendencies no cat you usually
castle in the car
no i would keep my king in the center um
if if i were to do this i would keep my
king in the center because it's an end
game i would play king e7 or king d7
and i would perhaps put a rook on g8
and if you think about it in contrast
the queens are off the board so it seems
ludicrous to talk about an attack
but in contrast to the position we saw
previously here the g
pawn is not as safe as it was uh
in in the other example where black was
the one of the panel trees because here
we have a dark sword bishop
and we have two pawns that can be
repurposed as battering rams in order to
break down this
palm g3 although it's still tremendously
robust
but i would keep liking in the center to
answer your question
okay so we also could have played bishop
e7 but that gives
him easy access to the f4 square
um yeah it can be worth going for the
minority attack there for sure
so we play h6 knight d2 bishop d6
this was uncalled for i don't know why
he took on c6 i mean
i guess this was his idea he was trying
to
organize um you know he was eventually
trying to occupy this outpost but it's
just not a very effective plan he's not
going to get this bishop away from d6
you want to castle short in these
positions generally castling long would
be way too risky
so what would i do with white i mean
there's
you know black's position is very
comfortable but maybe drop the bishop
back to d3
to get better control of the e4 square
and now one very typical plan in such
positions is to go rookie one
and then knight f1 and knight g3 kind of
like the rylo best plan
accumulating pieces on the king side
black is very very solid black also has
e5 in these kinds of positions
which gets an iqp position where black
is very very active so
generally he's got enough activity to
compensate for the weakness of the pawn
but um that would be one example of how
things could have unfolded here
it's just equal so he takes he goes
knight b3
now this pawn is not a big deal because
white is
just not going to be able to attack it
everything that you
consider to be a weakness you have to
ask yourself the question
is it realistic to assume that my
opponent will be able to attack that
weakness
the answer here is no why does no light
squirt bishop how is white even
hypothetically going to pile up on the
sea pawn it's
just not something to worry about here
okay
weakness versus exploitable weakness
it's very very important
to you know to to hold those two things
separately in your mind
something can be a weakness technically
but be completely unexploitable
such as a square or such as a um
such as a pawn and whether a weakness
is exploitable or not is far more
important than sort of
bogging yourself down or the semantics
of whether something actually is a
weakness thank you skye for the uh
uh extending the sub i have a good
example on that i always show this
example
i've shown this example more than once
on stream
because it's so instructive and it's a
great example of sort of in excess
i i wrote an article many years ago on
chess.com where i called this
inaccessibility
and i was talking mostly about weak
squares where like
players often hesitate to weaken squares
because they look very bad
but if a piece cannot get to a weak
square then you should feel free to do
it
uh then you should you shouldn't
hesitate to weaken that square
because everything in chess is very
concrete and so
this is one of my favorite examples on
the topic and then i'll show you one of
my games where i did something similar
and learned from this example
so so this is from 2013 this is a
battle between two super gm sergician
and tomaszewski
white is almost a super gm this is the
key position which occurred in their
game
um it's pretty clear that
white's got a minority attack going well
not even a minority attack just a queen
side attack going
and so the the most tempting move is is
b5 here
but uh tomaszewski had prepared after
abab
a counter strike what is this counter
strike
and where does it come from good night
it's really nice
what was uh tomaszewski planning was
planning e5
now this pawn on e3 is a backward pawn
and right now it's inaccessible
but e5 would make it accessible by
opening up the e-file so for example
after de-95 right
this pawn is now on a semi-open file
which is occupied by black's rook and
this knight
can then jump to c4 when this pawn
becomes a very much
exploitable weakness so this is a very
unpleasant
turn of events for white and so some of
chefs or sergey sion was thinking here
like
well can i do something about the threat
of e5 e5 is a very serious positional
threat
so what comes to mind and this is a move
which
seems tremendously anti-positional for
many
for two chief reasons and the move is f4
i think this is a brilliant move
precisely because it seems to violate so
many positional rules the first thing is
it creates a massive gaping hole on e4
so you're
immediately thinking of a nightmare
scenario where the knight appears on e4
black would basically be winning with
such a knight on e4
but obviously the catch is that the
knight can never get to e4
g5 is covered d6 is covered so the two
entry points are both covered
very reliably by white spawns
the knight can get there but it will
take like eight moves
one two
three then the king will have to move
this is really funny
four seven moves five six
and on the sixth move by the way white
can go bishop h4 and pin the knight to
the rook
seven and seven moves in chess is a
complete eternity
white on the other hand is one move away
from going b5 and crashing through on
the queen side
now the other reason that f4 might seem
like an anti-positional move is because
it
blocks in the bishop this bishop on g3
now seems totally
um totally dead but sergician realized
that
when he plays b5 he will have a chance
to activate this bishop via e1 e1 and a5
and the activity of the bishop is not
particularly important right now because
the knight is equally inactive
it's like this move is equally bad to
both minor pieces
but white's heavy pieces are better than
their counterparts so by taking the
minor pieces out of commission for the
time being
white allows himself uh to attack on the
queen side i know i don't know if that
makes sense
i think you get the point um
can black break with g5 well that's what
he did eventually black did break with
g5
and and the game was very complicated
like white is not winning here
very very far from it but white is
better and this was one of the reasons
why
he ultimately did win the game i don't
really want to analyze the rest black
eventually did break through with g5 he
had chances to draw
but white won in the end you can look at
this you can search this game up online
also
now i've also had uh examples where i
do something kind of similar in a much
much more basic level
so one example where i did something
that i was kind of proud of although it
was very very
i was already winning and just wasn't a
big deal at all
but i was nonetheless pretty happy with
the decision that i made
so so this was an old game from 2008
i was playing white and my opponent
was you know i actually took some
lessons from him and i was
just starting to play really nice guy
russian
class sort of classic rush in 2000 and
in this position he played i mean white
is better here clearly white's got peace
domination in the center
he played g5 which is kind of a creative
move and his idea
is that he's this is a car a method of
carving out i call this carving out
you're carving out a square for one of
your pieces
now what square is he trying to carve
out with this move
c-a-r-v carve what is he trying to carve
out
not the g6 square the e5 square yes the
e5 score is what black is trying to
ultimately uh gain for his pieces
so from that perspective i hesitated
before playing f5 because i thought well
this is a big deal this is a pretty
important square
then i thought no it's not my knight is
simply defending that square
so what are the odds that he eliminates
the knight
and then gets his knight over to e5
they're very very low
but uh what does f5 accomplish it makes
both of his bishops looks
look incredibly dumb in fact he
completely paralyzes his position
and after rookie 8 h4 the game is over
because this bishop is undefended i win
this pawn
black's position simply collapses here
so
i didn't hesitate before playing f5 or i
hesitated for a little bit but then
realized that my worries were completely
unfounded
now where does this lack of hesitation
come from final
detour before we come back to the
speed run game there was a very famous
game between fisher and zikr
where bobby did something very very
similar that is the game i took my
inspiration from
literally like move for move bobby did
something very very similar
although the position was far more
combative this is a very famous game
it's also in one of my articles so this
position it's an exchange rylopa as
black seems to be very very solid here
very solid i mean two bishops
solid central control bobby's got some
nice bonds in the center
what do you think fischer played in this
position this is a very instructive idea
i mean you already can just without even
understanding the move tell me because
this is exactly the same move that i
just played
so fischer plays i want somebody to find
it
f5 f5 is
i mean very clearly it locks the bishop
in it creates an outpost for the knight
but the key drawback is that it weakens
the e5 square and this seems to be a
very important square that black can now
occupy
that's kind of an illusion because after
queen e7
what piece can occupy this square well
the bishop bobby simply goes bishop f4
trading off the dark square bishops and
after the trade nothing will be able to
remain on e5 for very long
because the knight will eventually drop
back to f3 and chase away either the
queen or the rook
so the fact that this square is a
serious weakness is a complete illusion
in fact
not only is it not a weakness but bobby
uses that square and breaks through on
it with e5 and rookie four
eventually winning a very instructive
game so
this concept of weak squares as you
become stronger you realize that
sometimes you should weaken a square and
sometimes
a square being inaccessible for one
reason or another is a good reason
uh to allow it's it's weakening so
that's that's the bottom line
okay so back to the game we go queen c7
sorry for the long detour queen c7
stopping bishop f4 g3 and now a5
preparing to chase the knight drive the
knight away from b3
now in this position he could have
played a4 and prevented the pro
further progress of the apon but that
would have left the knight very much
undefended
so now rook b8 comes to mind or you can
castle first and then go rook b8 but the
knight is extremely loose here
so our opponent played knight c5 we take
it drop the knight onto e4
rookie one castles and now b4
i think b4 is a further mistake i think
that
bishop b3 preserves a reasonable
position for white although white is
definitely
worse here you can play rook b8 and then
double on the b
file and start targeting white's
weaknesses but knight c5 creates
uh pawn weaknesses on the queen side and
there was no need to do that i think
our opponent should have probably just
went here and dropped the knight back
and
black is maybe a tiny bit better but
nothing major
so i think knight c5 was a little bit of
panic
okay so castles before f5 cementing the
knight on e4
queen h5 and now queen e5 so again
knight c3
allows rook takes c6 and if you just
take the pawn up before thinking i'm
upon up
well now the bishop h6 is very very
strong because all of a sudden white's
accumulated all these pieces on the king
side why why calculate this
there's absolutely no need to go for
that
yeah so i blundered to be honest the
possibility of taking on c5 i just
missed that and in retrospect yeah we
should have just taken the spot i think
but after bishop f4
this does give white some activity for
his pieces
and that knight on e4 is pretty damn
good one thing that could happen is if
you're not careful
you could allow this bishop to hop onto
d6
and then you can't castle at all because
you don't have a dark squared bishop
these situations can be very very
unpleasant
so knight c5 is probably correct from a
computer standpoint then probably we
should go either queen e7 or queen d7 to
not allow bishop comes to d6 and then we
castle
okay so castles before f5 and queen e5
this is a chemo
attacking the pawn directly and
centralizing the queen
now he finds a very strong move bishop
h6 but i was proud of
the decision that i made here i think gh
is a very important move
that gives black a near decisive
advantage in the end game
now oh nice this guy that's nice
so why like what is the purpose behind
bishop hd well this is a pretty obvious
move actually
because both rooks are hanging the only
way to defend both of them is to move
the bishop
and also note that the knight is hanging
so if you just move the bishop to e3
then the knight's going to drop back to
f6 and black's
going to be totally fine so this is like
a desperado sacrifice knowing that
the knight on e4 is hanging
all right why didn't he defend the pawn
of bishop b2 so if you go
if you want bishop b2 here we take on b4
the bishop is undefended so cb is not
possible this is
completely devastating okay
so f3 queen c3 bishop h6
takes now he played oops sorry now he
played a very um
strong move queen g6 check that's
important
and um why is that move important
because if he would have taken
his uh our knight immediately and then
for example just taken
h6 he would have passed us the move and
we would have used this move just to
drop the queen back to f6 for example so
this is a nice
subtlety that allows him to take the e6
bond with check
the thing is after k8 we allow queen
takes h6 check that's unthinkable
so we go queen g7 and now we go queen f7
forcing the trade of queens
he can't not trade queens because then
he lets the knight escape
the reason the queen trade is very good
is because we now get this massive pawn
chain
which i think is essentially the reason
why the end game is winning this pawn
chain is
just devastating because two of these
pawns are past pawns
these are connected past spawns and i
think they essentially decide the game
in our favor even though material is
equal
if that makes sense so he goes with e3
which
technically is a mistake just gives up
another pawn which is
wasn't necessary but there was nothing
that he could have done if he plays a3
the simplest thing to do is to trade
everything
probably just to push the pawn you could
also go rook b7 if you're worried about
some sort of a pawn breakthrough this is
all completely winning
also important is the fact that the rook
attacked the king
uh yes we had a question after bishop h6
if we go knight f6 we allow queen g6 and
that's a key move
pinning the pawn to the king i saw what
you were thinking there but it doesn't
work
um so at fp rookie 3
ab4
yeah it's roy lopez but i don't know why
people are like
obsessing over that pronunciation i
usually i mean in russian you say
spanish game
like you don't say relopez lopez you say
spanish game but i i don't know it
doesn't really matter
yeah it's roy lopez or it's i don't know
it's it's
it's a roy lopez or rue lopez it should
be rui lopez
roy lopez i don't know i think yeah
either way is fine i think people
understand what's meant
okay so a3 rook b5 rylophus
king f2 takes and this is completely
winning this is very very easy okay guys
back to the game
it doesn't matter back to the game um
at this point we're up two pawns and the
game is over
so the only important move here was rook
b5
rook v5 um is important because it
attacks the c5 pawn
we cannot take on a3 because of rook
takes b7 so we bring the rook to a
defended square
understanding that he cannot take on b4
because his own rook is also pinned
and so now the game is totally did queen
check on d4 do anything at one point
like at the point where at this point
yeah queen d4 the problem is he drops
the bishop to e3
and now both the queen and the knight
are hanging so i thought about it but it
doesn't work for this reason
yeah and after we take yeah he
eliminates the night by force but still
this is completely winning so yeah that
was a nice game i mean
he played well to survive as long as he
did
and um
queen and king and game under time
pressure no we just pre-moved to try to
cut the king off from going where it
wants to go
you want to pre-move like close moves
moves that are only one square apart
generally that's one thing you want to
do well generally the uh
i i did a chess.com series on the art of
uh art of flagging
by the way you can check all of my tips
there i have a chapter on premoving
but the rook and pawn
game was i don't know if it was complex
i mean after i take the other pawn
all i'm really trying to do here is set
these pawns in motion
so c5 drive the king away
e3 d4 i'm just pushing the pawns i mean
i can't push them here
e2 he just takes d3 he takes this one so
we use the rook to supervise the
progress of the pawns
then we bring the king up the only issue
here is that amazingly
we can't push any of the pawns because
we give up its neighbor
so we have to use the king and bring it
to a good square so that it can
so that i can help the pawns move
further
all right um time for me to call it a
day guys i'm pretty exhausted
all right guys um i'll see you guys
later have a good start to the weekend
take care and uh goodbye for now
i'll see you guys later take care
everybody and have a great start to the
weekend a great
friday bye
[Music]
you